i like to talk to people that disagree
with me
so so it's just a civil conversation
no no i'm not i'm really not i believe
it's a cop-out for poor decisions and
the reason being is no no so there are
exceptions to every rule but less than
one percent of abortions are for in the
case of grape we say grape on youtube so
i'm not talking about the one percent of
cases i'm talking about the majority the
reason i think this is because 40 of
women that get an abortion have had two
or more abortions so to me it's saying
you're not being responsible at this
point and they're not tracking the 60 to
see how many get abortions in the future
to me it's you didn't make a good
decision when it first happens or
something like that when there's a woman
who's got single kids and she's he's
gonna make her a wealth gap that's the
thing in america so that's it so with
the people with like well they're rich
aren't they they're just gonna get it
done illegally are they not that's a
really not the poor people which i mean
so that's a really big misconception
okay so only eight percent of women
below the poverty line get abortions one
out of three women that make forty seven
thousand dollars per year actually are
getting an abortion on top of that in
the u.s planned parenthood which is the
number one provider of abortions it's a
racist organization started by a
eugenicist so her her she referred to
she referred to um black people as weeds
i just think to be illegal is to
complete it's complete regression into
us in like in society so um tell me why
because my body my choice do you know
what i mean let me do what i need to do
like men or whatever why should they
decide you know what i mean like why is
that a law why is that even a thing this
is a common argument i hear which is the
my body my choice so i'm i'm
i'm
i'm
if you want to be interviewed next you
can sorry i forgot what you said last i
just like that it's a regression in
society do you not think my body my
choice everything all of that so my body
my choice right
do you believe in abortion up to birth
so if i'm if i'm eight months pregnant
no i believe obviously but people you do
you believe life starts at conception is
that what you believe yeah when do you
believe that i think when it's
what the law is when it's like
up to six months is that that's what you
believe so here's the thing
an abortion is legal in the uk at 24
weeks and the earliest child to survive
a pregnancy is 21 weeks so you're
aborting children that hypothetically
could survive on their own outside the
world do you think that child that was
going to be born like the life that is
going to live do you think it's going to
live a good life and then isn't that
isn't that actually being cruel to this
child that would be born my question is
do you believe that poor children are
less valuable they're not less valuable
they're just not going to have a good
value of life so why should that why
should they why should i put a child on
this earth that's going to not not have
a good quality
when i could give it a good quality of
life when i'm prepared in the future
quality of life so one i have two things
one the majority of abortions are with
women that make over forty seven
thousand dollars per year so it's not an
income thing only only eight percent of
women anything do they i don't i don't
when you're firing back at these facts i
don't they don't mean anything you're
not a person like you do you and for 47
grand a year like do you earn that would
you have a baby right now could you
could you do that because to me i don't
think you should be having sex if you
can't afford a child and if you are if
you are then why why can't you get an
iud
or or or why can't you get an iud birth
control birth birth control in the uk is
free
doesn't always work does it
it but but this is a common argument i
hear which is we talk about exceptions
rather than the rule if you get you call
it the coil here i i think can i can i
find it can i i can i can i can i finish
my sentence so so the coil here is 99
effective you're actually really good at
debating yeah so i'll say that you're so
good at debating
here's the thing i'm not i'm not you're
here i'm not i'm not trying to clickbait
you i'm not i don't edit it out i know
you guys are just walking into this i
don't expect you to have the all facts i
just i just like to understand like why
you believe what you believe but do not
understand our point like the people
that are against it do you not
understand their point of view i think
their point of view is often it's my
body my choice right but i'm saying when
you take that to the extreme it doesn't
make sense have you had sex bo i'm i'm
not a virgin so you've had sex what if
you had a baby
but but i was i was i no but here so
so so here's the thing here's the thing
one if if i got pregnant i would keep it
because to me like i i don't believe in
abortion and i have um
i have i have a brother right and my mom
got pregnant when she was a teenager and
she gave him up for adoption and so to
me it's like do you think that's like
that's a life adoption usually kids that
are in adoptive care it's not a good
life in that sense no he had a great
life he's he's married pregnant yes he
had a great life doesn't mean a lot of
people go into drugs
i just want you to like when you say
things like that it's it's the same
argument people use for eugenics do you
know what eugenics says
so eugenics is basically when you're
when you're
getting a more pure population
and so a lot of times people would bring
things like low iq people need to be
exterminated like poor people need to be
exterminated and when you're using the
argument of if they have a bad life
that's how eugenicists use to make their
point because you're basically you're
implying that like poor people have less
of a right to life than rich people no
we're not we're not implying that i
think to do with it
if that baby is born when it could have
been aborted that could lead into a
worser life when it could have when that
could have been prevented
right so you don't think that's saying
that poor people should have a less of a
right to life than rich people it's not
about poor or rich like it's about
quality of life that has nothing to do
you could be poor and still have a good
quality of life like that has nothing to
do with it but like the baby like it's
quality of life like you don't know if
it's going to be rich you don't know if
it's going to poor you don't know where
it's going to end up and you can't just
you can't you can't just give birth
because what if it's not a good life
like some people can't even look after
themselves yet and you're putting a baby
with them okay this is the one thing
that people don't understand about
street interviews i am always excited to
talk to you guys if you see me on the
street whatever i am so down to talk but
if i'm doing an interview it hurts the
quality of the interview when you guys
interrupt me
when i am talking to the first person so
if you want to come up that's fine but
you have to like wait your turn
respectfully love you guys
but again so so
so so hey we're doing an interview i'd
love to interview you guys next i'd love
to hear
but so again only eight percent of women
below the poverty line so the majority
do you not think facts matter well not
in when this is uh other people
that that's becoming illegal now think
of all the things that are going to
happen in america
it's just going to it's going to be
terrible why is that your your thought
that everything like what's going to
happen
it was unlegalized in the first place
like because it wasn't happening it
wasn't unlegalized you might not know
how the u.s government works but it's
not illegal in the us it's not illegal
so
so the way it works in the u.s is it's
state by state so you elect officials to
represent you in each state and that way
if if you're a pro-life person you can
move to a state that's pro-life if
you're pro-choice you can move to a
state that's pro-choice why should you
have to move to a state why can't you
just well that's how the u.s government
works is you you have different laws in
every state
right
so again less than one percent of
abortion so but this is but so this is
this is my channel we talk about we
don't talk about exceptions we're
talking about the rule so you don't talk
about except we're talking because this
is what people often will try to make an
argument using the exception when we're
talking about the rule i'm i'm asking
you to like respectfully we're not we're
not talking about that exception
no because you're part of it i don't
know how you can come here and not want
to talk about the exception because 99
of abortions are due are not in the case
of grapes so we're talking about the 99
percent
i have nothing to offer i have nothing
for the 99 that's the argument i'm
making for the 99 of abortions that are
not great it is a cop out because they
made poor decisions
do you think about with
you don't you think that grapes so grape
youtube what do you think then i'm
asking what is your opinion on great and
yeah because i think you're again you're
trying to make an argument i think
you're trying to make an argument for
like the exception rather than the rule
and so this because because
because it's less than one percent of
the cases
but this is what because i'm not talking
about that i could see a potential
policy for exceptions but i'm talking
about the rule and the i would say okay
little things you might
it's a human concept construct that
you're there's the rule and the
exception it's still part of it do you
not see what i'm saying
but i but this is this is what i'm
talking about 90 the nine this is the
argument i'm making i i know but this is
this is you can do that on your channel
on my channel we're talking about the 99
of abortion that that are outside of
that case
you'll have you'll have like
most people here are going to talk about
that one percent yeah and i don't think
it's a good argument that's that's the
thing you can't even argue about it so
it clearly is a good argument because
you're done for you don't know what to
say because i i have an opinion on it
but we're not talking i wouldn't say i
wouldn't i would i wouldn't
okay but i'm here this is a job so again
like you're coming to my job and saying
this is you need to talk about what i
want on your channel
no it's just
okay would you okay so would you agree
that the 99 percent of cases it's a
cop-out outside of not at all
this isn't i don't think you're going to
change many people's lines in the uk
coming here you're it's actually
offending many people okay that's that's
okay yeah no it is
look at how many people have all passed
that's why we came over now
i was like what is on her like what are
you doing sorry no offense to you like
you're allowed to have your own choice
but we were in shock that's why we came
over because it's ridiculous i don't
it's crazy that you're kind of
brainwashed almost like that's our
opinion are we women america is
brainwashed they are crazy
yeah honestly like women can have an
opinion that doesn't agree with you i
have an opinion
but no i'm saying i don't think you're
brainwashed because you have your
opinion so it's a little bit offensive
when you say that i'm brainwashed
because i disagree with you because
i don't i don't think you're brainwashed
i think you just have your opponent i
think in the respect that you're saying
ignore that i think that's why i think
that ignore that exception that's what
that's made us the argument i'm making
isn't in the cases of great that's not
the argument i'm saying in 99 of cases
it is a cop-out
and this is the thing i'm not offended
and i think a lot of girls are afraid
they're going to hurt my feelings ladies
i do this every day i am not offended
the point is just to show you that you
have a flaw in logic and it's very
frustrating to me when if i say i am pro
life they try to degrade everything that
i said before it doesn't matter to them
it doesn't matter to them if the facts
the data the statistics are all on my
side it's still
oh well you're pro-life you're
brainwashed
okay what's your name umali